all right so hello everyone a very warm
greeting to one and all my name is Sri
gauri Krishna Kumar and I would like to
welcome you all for the second webinar
on microbiome in Health and Wellness
hackathon so for those of you who are
new to this webinar welcome and we are
organizing a hackathon on microbiome in
health and wellness this November to
provide students with a platform to
Showcase their Innovative mindset of
problem solving and in this hackathon
each student will have the opportunity
to develop a mini project around the
hackathon topic form a team with at
least two other students and compete
against others for mentorship support
from established companies and long-term
interests from the business community
and the applications of hackathon are in
the fields of obesity and Precision
Nutrition Innovation and beauty products
and pregnancy
in our previous webinar we discussed
week one topics on microbiome business
that will that will be covered during
the training duration we were joined by
Mr Elia brotsky CEO of spine biotech who
discussed what the hackathon is about
what kind of opportunities are present
for students and researchers who are
participating in the hackathon the
participants of the webinar were also
joined by Dr raghavendra Lakshmi Narayan
computational biologists and research
consultant at Pine biotech he discussed
what is microbiome how bioinformatic
approaches help understand Association
of microbial population with disease and
popular research Publications that will
provide ideas for students participating
in the hackathon
in today's webinar we will be first
introducing the participants to the week
2 workshop on biotechnology where we
will be covering the topics on gut
microbiome health and diet skin
microbiome Beauty comfort and aging and
vaginal microbiome pregnancy and
symptoms
so before we begin with today's webinar
for those of you who are joining for the
first time let me also take a brief
moment to introduce you to the team
behind the program we are a us-based
benchmatics company who is working with
multiple academic and Commercial
collaborators to develop easy to use
analytical tools and our mission is to
make bioinformatics more accessible
and as a part of the hackathon students
will have access to the omics logic
training that has been completed by over
24 000 participants from 187 countries
in over 300 workshops and due to this
fast quote our team is working with
local and Regional coordinators that are
helping to find local program Logistics
and adapting them to the needs of
students and researchers around the
world and this training has been
completed by participants in six
different specialization tracks that
includes oncology infectious diseases
Precision medicine Neuroscience data
science for biomedical data and
comprehensive training on omic's data
analysis
as a part of the hackathon students will
also have access to the omics logic
resources but how does it help
advancementics teaching omox logic is a
portal for practical and theoretical
learning of bandformatics it takes a
combination of frame modules data
analysis tools curated project data sets
and interactive sessions with mentors to
give the student a clear path of the
blooms taxonomy permit no matter what
the user's initial experience with
bioinformatics is omic's logic is a
useful tool for gaining a baseline
knowledge of the theory behind
bioinformatics analysis of data sets and
introduction to basic coding languages
like R and python or even beginning a
data analysis project
this also comes with an access to omex
logic courses which includes courses on
bioinformatics Precision medicine
multiomics including genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics apigenomics
data science that includes
bioinformatics using iron python as well
as chem informatics users will be given
directions to access the T by info
platform for benchmatic processing and
Analysis of data and the platform
includes demo pipelines as well as data
management and Analysis Cloud
infrastructure to run the biosomatic
pipeline and different stages of the
analysis are performed in different
sections on this multinomics platform
so first of all we need to sign up on
the omics project learn portal but
before that let me walk you through a
brief demo on what a completed profile
on the portal looks like
once you sign up on the portal these are
the features that you need to update on
your account that is a completed profile
will have a profile image full name with
appropriate capitalization linked to
your social media handles this could be
your Facebook LinkedIn Instagram or
kaidi or even Twitter a brief bio about
yourself that will consist of your
education background and research
interests the mentors can view your
progress under the activity tab the
courses you are currently completing
will appear under the courses Tab and
finally after the completion of your
course the certificates will appear
under the certificates tab once you sign
up on the portal you will also be able
to view the various courses and example
projects that will help you prepare for
the hackathon one course that I would
like to bring to your notice whether you
are a beginner to the field of matter
genomics or you're an intermediate or
expert willing to refresh your metagen
of Concepts I would like to direct you
to course 2 bytes and molecules this
course is intended for all those who are
interested in understanding how the
current revolution in biomedical data
impacts biomedical research and human
health in this course the lesson that
will be of relevance for the
participants will be lesson 8
introduction to metagenomics in this
lesson you will explore how different
types of analysis can be used to
understand the microbial world and
practice several biasmatical approaches
to the analysis of the microbiome
finally to check your understanding the
lesson ends with a simple quiz if you
wish to proceed ahead and gain an
in-depth understanding of the
metagenomic concepts you can opt for
Cores for metagenomics in this course
you will learn about processing 16s rrna
data with data to visualizing o2u
abundance tables for diversity using
philosophy package that can help build
phylogeny aware species richness Alpha
diversity plots and beta diversity plots
and so much more to help build these
concept course use practical quizzes
Hands-On demo pipelines and our
programming for data visualization
once you gain a thorough understanding
of the key concept involved in the
metagenomics data analysis one can start
by going through one of the relevant
example project the example projects are
sourced from high impact research
Publications that will provide students
with the logic behind conducting a
research topic for instance the example
project on role of high fat diet on
Obesity aims to understand the microbial
diversity after feeding high fat and
normal diet in mice and decipher its
role in obesity and underlying diseases
all the example projects follows a
similar format where students are
initially given an overview of the
important Concepts to carry out the
example project this is followed by
identifying a gap in the literature and
understanding the significance of the
research question proposed once done the
students knowledge are tested through
quizzes and assignments to provide
Hands-On practical experience students
are given step-by-step guideline to
building bioinformatic pipelines on the
T bioinfo server and this section that
will be available for today's discussion
is the metagenomic section
for this example project they're already
accessed a demo pipeline under the name
ciao versus hft in this example we are
making use of 16 is metal genomic
pipeline
this is an example of how we will carry
out the balance Max Pipeline the input
files will consist of pickle samples
collected from the mice and our aim here
is to analyze the microbial microbial
diversity the pipeline is based on
running a number of programs including
data to aim and phyloc and the functions
of each of these algorithms have been
thoroughly explained in the course after
running the pipeline we received several
outputs including file of c bar plot
abundance table file of sleep abundance
plot abundance heat map whose
interpretation has been explained as
well in the course the course also
introduces the Learners to perform in
Downstream analysis of 16s amplicon data
using our programming and how to
interpret the resulting output
some of the other example projects that
one could look into are effective
dietary fiber intake or microbiome this
example project aims to determine the
microbial composition of obese and
normal weight subjects and identify
microbial changes after weight loss diet
another interesting project that one
could look into is the effect of
non-antibiotics and wet syndrome this
example project aims to understand the
change changes in microbial Community
after the administration of
non-antibiotic drugs to understand how
they affect the neurological dysfunction
so now you might be wondering what comes
after the courses after completing the
courses and example projects and the
answer is possibilities are endless for
instance you could go on to perform a
research project like this a
bioinformatics graduate from Amity
University Rajasthan who completed a
research project on the composition of
gut microbiota of samples infected with
liver cancer she uploaded a project on
loan portal where an International
Community of students peers and
bioinformatics experts can watch her
presentation recording read through the
research project like share and comment
their feedback under the comment section
another interesting student project
outcome can be seen in case of de la
taikin a molecular biology and genetics
graduate from University of turkey who
completed a project on metagenomics and
Astronaut Health which she went on to
present at the scionics club session a
session where an International Learning
Community of bioinformatic enthusiasts
come together to share their work debate
on important topics and share their
queries to stay up to date with latest
advancements in the field in addition
she also went on to publish her project
as a preprint on bioarchive that she can
share with her peers mentors and
potential employers for future
connections
further you could also participate in
research Symposium and showcase your
work such as omic's research Symposium
where one of the participants who
presented her project on comparison of
microbiome data of different lung
diseases on cash prices for the first
price for best technical research
project this Symposium is an
international research Symposium that
brings together experts such as Dr
Garrett trouble staff scientists at
Lawrence Livermore National Laboratory
and Dr Joseph Borg associate professor
and principal investigator at University
of Malta amongst so many other experts
who join as guest speakers and judges so
to view courses and example projects
various programs student project let us
Begin by signing up on the Onyx logic
learn portal for that I'm sharing the
link in the chat box please click on the
link and I'll walk you through the
process behind signing up on the portal
so here is the link
so
all right so once you click on the link
you'll be able to view the mystogic
learns sign up page for users who do not
have an existing account on the portal
you can click on the create an account
option that you see here
and here you will be asked to enter your
name email ID providing your password
you can also have the option to sign up
using any of your social media accounts
such as Google Facebook Apple account
GitHub account or even Twitter
so with that I will pause for a couple
of minutes so that the participants can
visit the page and start signing up on
the portal if you are facing any
technical issues please put them in the
chat as well so that I can help you for
signing up on the portal
once you have signed up on the portal
please put a yes in the chat box so that
I know we are good to proceed
so I'm monitoring the chat box mean time
[Music]
all right the laba has already signed up
Mansi has also signed up
so we have more than 25 plus
participants and I am expecting a yes
from almost all of them
if you are facing any queries you could
put them in the chat as well
so since I already have an account on
the portal I'm going to click on the
login now option
so here I could just click on the sign
in and I could
enter the code so once you sign up you
first enter the courses tab page here if
you scroll down and here if it will ask
for if you're looking for a specific
course so since most of the participants
are interested in the meta genomics
field I'm going to enter the keyword
that is metagenomics there you go you
have the course and the various example
projects that you could visit and check
and you could start dating so one of the
important part that I explained before
was uh like was to set up your profile
for that click on the tab that says
welcome back with your email ID and here
you will be able to see the icon that
says profile here you will be able to
enter your details such as your
education background research interest
your name and in my case I've linked my
LinkedIn account and my old id so under
the activity tab the mentor and the
community manager will be able to track
your learning progress under the courses
tab
the participants will be able to view
the various courses that they are
currently taking so for instance I just
recently started taking up the example
project on non-antibiotics and red
syndrome is really interesting project
and I would highly urge all of you to
check it out and once you've complete a
research project like Ghazal you can
upload it under the project staff and if
you wish to enroll for any of the
programs and then you'll be able to view
the programs under the program staff and
finally after the completion of the
courses you will be able to receive the
certificates under the certificates tab
and finally to view the various student
projects you can click on the projects
that you see here and you could see a
wide variety of projects on oncology
Neuroscience Agriculture and so on so
now I'd like to pass on the stage to one
of my colleagues sonalika Ray who will
be explaining how you can leverage the
technical resources that are available
on the T by engine platform so over to
you soon
thank you so much sugar for the overview
hello everyone I am sonalika Ray I'm the
bioinformatics project manager here at
Pine biotech and I'll be discussing
about metagenomics it's Evolution
sequencing types several ways to process
metagenomic data to pick the right
method I'll briefly discuss about the
two major analysis in order to make you
understand how easy the analysis could
be and finally showcase some interesting
visuals that are obtained by running
these pipelines that makes biological
interpretation easy and efficient so
first of all to talk about the
connection between disease and
microorganisms that has been established
in the 1800s these studies provided
important information about bacteria
function in isolation however it became
apparent that most microorganisms live
in complex communities many members of
which are impossible to culture in
isolation
today we know that the microorganisms or
the microbiota that make up the human
microbiome are not just unicellular
organisms living alongside each other
but instead form highly regulated
structurally and functionally organized
communities attached to surfaces as
biofilms within the species
collaborations as well as antagonisms
that contribute to ecologic stability
however since the 1990s microbiome
studies were significantly Advanced
through such major initiatives as the
metagenomics of human intestinal tract
and the subsequent human microbiome
project huge studies that have been made
possible through the advances in
metagenomic sequencing as a result skin
lung gut and even brain microbiota is
starting to be characterized each new
project represents vast opportunities
and challenges to determine which
microorganisms play key roles in the
development of certain environmental
conditions needed for healthy function
of human organs and which can be harmful
to it
due to the advances and metagenomic
sequencing and other omics Technologies
enormous database of sequence data from
such communities has led to the
emergence of computational metagenomics
which can help study the 99 percent of
uncultivable microorganisms in the
context of their natural environment
unlike other omics metagenomics does not
study a single organism but the whole
community at once a snapshot of a
collection of organisms directly in
their natural environment since the
genomes are so diverse this is typically
accomplished by sequencing a specific
marker portion of the genome instead of
all the genomic material present in a
given sum
and why I'm telling you all about this
is because you'll have to work with such
data in the duration of the hyperton
those sequencing principles vary between
different sequencing approaches to
mention the main difference alumina
specializes in short redraw sequence
data while Park bio focuses on Long
reads or sequence data and the each per
flow cell of Oxford nanotechnology is
much higher than Pac bio because each
nanopore can sequence multiple molecules
now let's briefly discuss about the
types of metagenomic sequencing
techniques one is whole metagenom
sequencing or shotgun metagenome
sequencing that is relatively new and
Powerful sequencing approach that
provides insights into Community
biodiversity and function the other one
is 16s amplicon sequencing that is
recently developed technique and is
widely used to study microbiome directly
in its environment such metagenomic
sequencing focuses on 16s or 18s
ribosomal RNA that has to be Amplified
with PCR amplification
the 16 inch Gene sequences contain
hyper-variable regions which are also
known as hvrs that provide species
specific signature sequences useful for
bacterial identification the benefit of
amplification is tied to the nature of
sequencing grid length which can
maximize effective output from
affordable sequencing Technologies
to account for the diversity of
subsequences they are usually combined
into operational taxonomic units or otus
which can be used to classify group of
closely related individuals
otos are formed from groups of closely
related genomic sequences and they
represent a cluster or a phylogenetic
plate that has a meaningful abundance in
a sample
such ODU sequences are annotated by
mapping onto a reference database such
as that of ribosomal database project
green genes or the silver database and
such databases contain taxonomic
information for the domains of bacteria
Archaea and the Eukarya based primarily
on phylogenes for small subunit rrnes
16s for prokaryotes and 18s for euchara
let's not talk a little bit about the
Practical analysis approach to analyze
metagenomic data on the team bioinfo
platform once analysis is processing the
data to pipeline that is based on
running a number of programs including
data to ape and phylosync algorithms
data do generates amplicon sequence
variance of the ASV tables which are
similar to otu tables but detailed in
that they tabulate the number of
identical amplicon sequence variants
from different samples microbial studies
utilizing data 2 provide high resolution
accurately reconstructed amplicon
sequences that improve the detection of
sample diversity and the biological
variance the data to pipeline implements
a complete pipeline to turn the paired
and fastq files from the sequencer into
merged denoised Chimera free infert
sample sequencing
by using the data to algorithm find
scale variations are identified and a
quality based model is produced we will
end up with most denoised Chimera free
inferred sample sequences data to
analysis will filter input data
de-replicate providing abundances of
unique sequence data and an ASV table a
denoised high resolution output file
the results obtained from the data to
pipeline includes a microbial abundance
taxonomy bar plot a related on a
proportionate plot indicating the
richness and abundance of taxa
identified
pilocy clots based on the otu abundance
2D and 3D PCA plots to visualize the
cluster separation between the samples
of the data set Alpha diversity measure
that some arises the structure of an
ecological Community with respect to its
richness
now let's talk about the kind 2 pipeline
the kind 2 pipeline is an open source
bioinformatics pipeline for performing
microbiome analysis for from raw DNA
sequencing data the chyme is designed to
take users from raw sequencing data
generated on the Illumina or other
platforms to publication quality
graphics and statistics this includes
demultiplexing and quality filtering
Oto picking taxonomic assignment and
phylogenetic reconstruction and
diversity analysis along with
visualizations chyme has been applied to
study to studies based on billions of
sequences from tens of thousands of
samples
the advances in the analysis of amplicon
sequence data sets have introduced a
methodological shift in how research
teams investigate microbial biodiversity
away from sequence identity based
clustering producing operational
taxonomic units or the otus to denoising
methods producing applicant sequence
variables kind to plugins in the
pipeline on the team bioinfo server
exist for latest generation tools for
sequence quality control from different
sequencing platforms data 2 and D blur
taxonomy assignment and phylogenetic
insertion which quantitatively improves
the result the platform provides many
interactive visualization tools
facilitating exploratory analysis and
result reporting
along with the data 2 pipeline results
which included taxonomic part plots PCA
and Alpha diversity measure kind to
pipeline also provides lists of results
that you could see here on the screen
which includes the alpha diversity box
plot which determines if an environment
has been sequenced to a sufficient depth
through evenness group significance and
Faith group significance plots
it includes kind to alpha Air fraction
which illustrates the number of samples
in each group kind to remove eukaryotic
generates an interactive bar plot of
taxa present in the samples it also
includes group significance plots which
include Alpha and beta group
significance and kind to core Matrix an
area of Alpha and beta diversity
measures that can be generated with a
single command of Kindle the kind
diversity code Matrix phylogenetic
command reduces both phylogenetic and
non-phylogenetic measures as well as
Alpha and beta diversity measures and
then we have the core Matrix
phylogenetic command that generates a
plot as you can see here on the extreme
uh right side that includes the jakart
distance that includes the qualitative
measure of community dissimilarity break
your test distance which includes again
a quantitative measure of community
dissimilarity and weight unifract
distance and we a journey flag distance
I hope you will now agree with me that
analysis isn't always complicated there
is a logic behind it and once you
understand the logic behind it then it
is easy for you to understand today what
I presented was a very brief overview of
the flow from the metagenomic study to
what other various sequencing types and
then what are the different analysis
types and showcase you the resources
that you could use during your duration
of hackathon and utilize so now to
discuss how the resources could be used
effectively to build a solution or a
product of your own I would like to pass
it on to our CEO Mr India Brodsky over
to uvilia
thank you sonarika and great to see you
all here I would like to speak briefly
about the context the business context
of some of these analysis tools and
project examples that you've talked that
already we heard about
so one of the challenges in
bioinformatics in general
is that bioinformatics seems to be
detached from practical challenges and
problems so the hackathon is an
opportunity to connect biotechnology or
where the data is getting generated and
what to do with that data to
bioinformatics where we focus on
analysis approaches and insights from
data with real-world problems and these
are defined in business terms
so as someone who has started several
different companies in the past it has a
lot of experience and success and
failure in a lot of these companies I
know that there are several important
things to think about as you approach
this hackathon
so the first one is what problem are we
solving and how are we solving this
problem
the second one is what does the solution
really look like and who is going to use
that solution and then what is the
business value proposition how does this
solve a business problem that someone is
willing to pay for
so the objective of the hackathon is to
connect these together and allow student
teams or research teams to try and
propose some of these problems and face
the uh kind of real world challenges and
opportunities that the microbiome has
produced
so one important aspect of this is
really how to narrow down the many
different opportunities that are out
there that align with your interests and
have the potential to be interesting to
investors users or companies that you
might work with or for
so as someone who maybe comes from a
biotechnology bioinformatics or a
research background you might be
thinking how can I leverage some of my
understanding of this field and what the
potential of the microbiome holds to
really showcase my skills and
understanding of how this could work in
a very very practical way and so this is
going to be
critical uh to understand Beyond just
kind of the technical things that we've
already heard about and focused on what
does this solution really look like
so the first subject that you will have
to decide is what problem will you solve
and we separated this hackathon into
three specific problems the first one is
gut microbiome and again we are focused
on pre-clinical uh challenges and
problems so the reason for that is
because when you start going into
clinical problems there's all kinds of
ethical as as well as regulatory issues
that we just don't have the time to
address so
this hackathon is going to be focused on
pre-clinical opportunities so what are
some opportunities with microbiome for
health and wellness the immediate thing
that comes to mind of course is obesity
uh General kind of Health and Wellness
but it becomes a lot more detailed as
you start looking at the data so what we
will do for that particular challenge is
bring you experts that have seen
multiple companies that are trying to
innovate in that space and connect
insights from microbiome studies to
specific challenges like obesity or
pre-clinical conditions like
pre-diabetic you know patients and and
people who experience negative results
of obesity to try and solve them with
different types of interventions and
we'll talk about what opportunities are
there what other companies are trying to
do how you might differentiate and what
is the real value proposition for some
company or idea or a product that wants
to kind of you know disrupt the market
and do something different
the second field
is related to Beauty aging and skin
microbiome so the skin microbiome is
very different from the gut microbiome
and that leads to specific methods of
sequencing data preparation analysis
Etc and so what we will do is we will
curate several examples that during the
month of November we will actually
share some insights from and we will
bring some experts who are actively
pursuing this opportunity with skin
microbiome and have identified some
interesting Trends and maybe special
opportunities that you could focus on as
well
the third one
is related to the general topic of
femtech so femtech refers to
um you know technology that can help
address issues like pregnancy healthy
pregnancy healthy birth uh conception
and things like that and so what is
important there is that you know you
need to understand uh how real data can
inform us about these things in general
as a research problem but then also how
can we take insights from these research
questions and turn them into practical
actual tools or products that people
will use so one example of a product
could be a recommendation engine and so
we will spend some time speaking about
what is a recommendation engine how can
we use insights from microbiome data
analysis and Link it to other types of
information like diet physical activity
genetic background and environment
so what's important is to be able to use
some kind of an analytical approaches to
be able to categorize different types of
interventions suggest combination of
steps that need to be taken and also to
monitor progression we will also talk
about who is your audience and the
importance of understanding your
audience and how they view a potential
product so here what's going to be
important is to think of you know the
age range the background maybe in terms
of how where people work what do they
know what is their education level and
to be able to analyze that data and come
up with real clear understanding of what
is the market that you're trying to
approach with your solution
so we'll talk about
um some of the challenges and
opportunities that existing companies on
the market have faced for example a lot
of the companies that are already making
microbiome testing available on the
market are facing a problem of
knowledge and understanding of what the
microbiome can do for them cost of
sequencing and cost of these tests so
how much people are willing to pay for
some of these tests or even the their
ability to follow the instructions that
you know maybe these tests will
recommend right purchase additional Pro
and prebiotics change their dietary
habits Etc
so then we'll talk about what is the
product right what really could you
um propose
as your ultimate solution and that can
fall into several different categories
so it can fall into the category of a
real physical product for example a pre
or a probiotic that could be a pill that
could be a cream uh you know it could be
some kind of a marketable product that
is physical and then you face additional
challenges right where are you going to
Source those specific
interventions how are they going to be
packaged who are they going to be sold
through Etc
uh maybe you're thinking of a product
idea that is an application uh that the
users will use on their smart watch or
their iPhone or you know some kind of a
mobile device
um that could be an option as well and
there you need to think about well what
exactly is it going to do where's the
data going to come from and what kinds
of insights are going to be made
available
and then you could also be might be
thinking about a product that is not for
a customer it's maybe for a company so a
company will need a very different type
of insight compared to a user right so
instead of an individual and their
recommendations they might want to look
at comparison between multiple
individuals or multiple types of
products or multiple types of challenges
so really it's a platform kind of an
idea foreign
we will talk about how to define your
competition in terms of the value chain
for example there are many different
microbiome testing kits on the market
how are they different from each other
why do each one of them uh you know
claim that they are the most advanced or
the most comprehensive how do we
actually know if they're more advanced
or more comprehensive and then based on
their pricing how can we identify who is
going after the low pricing strategy
who's going after the high and premium
kind of a product strategy and how can
you position yourself and differentiate
sufficiently from this competition to
offer something new different and
valuable to your target market we'll
also talk about some of the trends in
the market which areas have been tried
which areas remain to be tried and what
is successful what is not successful
what is growing what is kind of
diminishing what are some of these
trends that are important to look at
finally we will talk about how your
solution can capture the market so as a
whole we know that the market is growing
at a fairly rapid Pace
at the same time we know that investors
are becoming concerned with new
companies just proposing kind of
marketing campaigns of the same
Solutions focused on just pricing
differences so really there is going to
be a challenge not only to develop an
idea about the product but also Define
how can this product be introduced now
of course this is not going to be
something that you have to figure out
completely over the course of the full
hackathon the idea here is really to
think through all of these different
stages
understanding the microbiome space from
a technology and from the value
proposition sides combining this
understanding with a practical
opportunity in one of the three areas
that we already defined and then working
with a mentor to get enough feedback
about your proposal so that you can
actually present something meaningful
and valuable at the hackathon end
so with that
that key
um kind of result from all of this is
going to be your demo and the demo is
primarily a uh presentation so the
presentation will address your
um you know insights so this must be
based on real data again we will provide
you with some examples of data but we
will also talk about other repositories
of data that you could leverage to gain
insights and so you can use either the
tools that we have described today or
your own analysis pipeline but the main
idea would be that whatever your
proposed solution is it is based on
insights that are rooted in real data
sets these data sets might not be
comprehensive they might not answer all
of the questions but there is enough
evidence that this is realistic and
important
the second will be your market research
analysis so how have you analyzed the
market itself uh the competition that is
out there how many people or companies
will be using your product and what are
some trends that are important to
understand in terms of regulatory
Frameworks uh you know opportunities for
monetization and things like that
the next point will be about product
design what is this is this a physical
product is this an application is this a
platform
um is this some kind of uh you know
report that you are spelling or that you
are proposing to develop
um and how will that be used by real
users where will they find out about it
how will they you know produce data that
will be ingested what would be the
results of that analysis what would be
the actual points at which they need to
interact maybe with support or you know
consultation or something like that so
thinking through all of those aspects of
the product so to say
the value proposition so how is this
product solving that problem that people
are willing to pay for right and what is
the alternative that maybe they have to
avoid to choose this proposal that you
have
then we'll talk about go to market
strategy are you going to advertise and
sell on Amazon are you going to develop
an app and put it on the you know um
iPhone or Android platforms are you
going to you know organize some kind of
a marketing campaign with hospitals or
Wellness Center centers you know what
exactly is your strategy and how
realistic is that strategy what needs to
happen for that to be successful and
then finally what is the business value
so what is the business value that is
being produced by using this solution
are these new insights that are somehow
valuable to companies are these
recommendations that people can use are
they going to stay with it just for you
know one time or is this going to be a
continuous value that is generated and
maybe to multiple users at the same time
so really the culmination of this
hackathon
is going to be about how you can
contextualize your understanding of
biotechnology your bioinformatics
capabilities and your uh kind of
understanding of data analysis
approaches like algorithms and user
interfaces to produce some kind of a
business value and we hope that as a
result you will showcase your ability to
think differently
um kind of understand the market and
propose real innovative solutions and
connect with experts in the field
companies as well as investors that are
ready to consider in a more serious way
some of the ideas that you might have
so with that I would like to um pass it
on to ayushi I guess to talk about the
schedule of the hackathon and the
registration
um
or who is going to cover that it would
be me so
um so let me share my screen for
discussing that
okay
it's my screen visible
um I'm unable to share my screen one
moment
okay
so is my screen visible now okay yeah
okay so in this part of the presentation
I will be discussing about the program
registration details so as discussed
I'll just quickly recap the resources
that you get as a part of this uh a
hackathon so first of all you'll have
access to the research and computational
infrastructure through the T Bar info
platform you will also have access to
the omic statute training resources that
comprise of online coursework support
and mental guidance
and finally it all it will also comprise
a practical example project data sets
case studies that we have discussed in
our previous slides
and finally you will have access to
expert workshops and mental guidance uh
the week one Workshop will be on
microbiome business and the topics
covered will be microbiome health and
wellness omics and microbiome
Technologies banned Matrix for Health
and Wellness
and the second week of the workshop will
focus on biotechnology topics such as
gut microbiome skin microbiome and
vaginal microbiome
and the week 3 Workshop will be focusing
on the computer science topics that will
be uh for infrastructure for
computational analysis tools methods and
algorithms machine learning data
visualization and user experience
so the main event will be conducted from
November 23rd to November 28th uh in
between this period you will be required
to develop a minimal viable product and
you'll be able to press during the main
event and that you will be also able to
receive certification and recognition
and exciting crash prices and funding
opportunities and for the speakers and
the judges who will be participating we
have a wide network of experts who will
be participating such as Liliana and all
back
and here are some of the important days
that you need to keep in mind that is
the registrations open on has been open
on September 30th and it is still
ongoing the registrations will close on
October 31st and the hackathon training
program will start from November 1st and
the hackathon event will be held from
November 23rd to November 28th and to
get all the details that we have
discussed in this webinar as well as the
previous webinar you can simply visit
the main hackathon page that you see
here I am pasting the link in the chat
box
so here if you just click on the button
that you that says register for the
microbiome and health and wellness
hackathon a form you'll be redirected to
a form here you will be asked to enter
some of your details such as your name
email ID and if you once you register
once you fill up the form you'll be able
to get all the latest updates that are
happening with that are happening with
the hackathon
now coming to the registration course
part so once you scroll through here you
will be able to view the registration
cost for different categories of the
participants so if you are an individual
participants you can register for dollar
100 and if you're participating as a
group of students you can register for
Toler 300 and if you're a student from
one of the partner universities you can
register for dollar hundred so to know
if your University is a part of our
partnership program you can simply visit
the link that you see here
that is the main page for the
partnership University program so you
can browse through and check if your
university has been listed under our
partnership University program
and then coming to the payment checkout
so each of it has been divided in
different categories so here if you were
to click on the respective category that
you're participating you'll be asked to
enter some of the main details and once
you enter all the main details you will
be able to make the payment and you'll
be able to register for me
so with that if anyone have any queries
so far please put them in the chat box
and our team will be happy to help you
I'm also sharing the contact details of
our marketing manager so that if you're
having inquiries you can reach out to
her at your own pace
so
we'll just wait for a couple of minutes
so that if participants are having any
queries we can take them up
foreign
thank you so much for this excited to
participate yes we are excited to have
you as well so all the very best to the
lava for participating in the hackathon
so in the meantime while we are waiting
let me just briefly navigate through the
main page hackathon page here you will
be able to see the various topics under
which the hackathon are based on such as
obesity and Precision Nutrition skin and
beauty products pregnancy and fantech
and here once you scroll down you're
also able to see the various uh topics
that will be covered during each of the
uh experimental workshops of three weeks
and you can also browse through and see
us uh the various speakers who will be
participating such as missing again and
our back she's a Serial entrepreneur and
uh investor in high-tech biotech
companies with a demonstrated history of
co-founding and growing several
companies with successful exits so if
the participate if the participants are
participating in the hackathon uh it's a
really great opportunity I would hope I
I would highly urge all of them to
participate
in the hackathon
so we're waiting for the queries if
anyone have any queries you can put them
in the chat
[Music]
or you can unmute yourself and speak as
well
if you're having any queries
otherwise we are good to end with
today's meeting and I hope to see you
all for the next webinar that will be
conducted on October 27th
so with that I'd like to end today's
video
so thank you everyone have a great day
okay Stephen has raised his hand
uh yes Stephen
yeah thank you so much for the
presentation